here we go folks into the gameplay we're
going to see some rifle gameplay now
just look at the scope look how
beautiful the weapon loses one of those
things I like to play with a sniper
rifle wow it's a real later it's a roll
way like if you get the kill you
fulfilling really deserve it and now we
do look at those weapons people wow
that's absolutely beautiful other detail
on top it's all get about detail look at
that explosion and you see right there
they have a ground deformation that
happened when that tank blew up it's
sent you know obviously just shake the
ground underneath the water bayonet
chops Oh got him got him Oh Jesse
Wellens you poor thing I'm so sorry that
was really cool to see that was so
entertaining but what we were talking
about is that the bayonet challenge is
like more than a sprint you know you're
going into a mad rage like you're gonna
take this player down and right there
that's the first Oh are we going for
another one no all I didn't quite get
there but then you can see you can see
right it's a trade-off isn't it if
you're going to push yourself if you're
going to go for that bayonet charge you
can't do anything else once you've
committed so there's a chance you could
get taken out I mean you ran he runs up
to the window he tries to kill the guy
the guy gets away and well then
obviously you need to pay the price yeah
no matter like what terrain you know
like if you hit a wall right essentially
is what I'm trying to get a bit of wall
you're stopped right in your tracks
there's nothing you can do you're slow
down you can't sprint again you can't do
anything I believe you could still shoot
your gun though I think you can still do
they still make sure that happens to
defend yourself but any kind of mobility
they'll become severely limited which of
course is an issue if you're in the
thick of things if you're right in the
heart of the battlefield and you go in
for the charge you pay the price if you
don't get that one I don't miss me if
you're going to the
you're focusing on that right here so
you might forget that you can still fly
when maybe get yourself out on the
situation but you're going for that
player so you're intent on game
sometimes you just begin yeah very true
you know we covered a lot of elements in
the game here and I know that you know
the community I'm sure has a lot of
questions about what if you can and
cannot do I believe some weapons also
have different firing options as well at
the leaf so yeah that's like a couple
that I played it was one that single
shot one that could do automatic fire so
there's some of the weapons you know
mechanics that you guys are familiar
with in other Battlefield games you know
are certainly there for you to be able
to switch out the weaponry and or switch
off the style of play right where the
yelling go for more steady shot or maybe
you want a little bit more ammunition
things like that I'm getting the fray
yep get in there these are some brave
cinematic shots they are really good
they show off the environment really
well and obviously you can see this bit
here looking like pristine countryside I
mean yeah we've got a little bit of a
little bit of destruction down here at
the barber that's quite a bit of
destruction man but you know I mean like
it was pristine when we started and you
can bet your life that it's been
completely level to play the end of the
round so oh boy boy here's Stone
Mountain trying his best here we're in
there this is one of the actual ruin
villages this is part of the map already
ruined as it goes along and as you go to
the other side you've got the pristine
countryside there's a nice variation of
the same map you can always make
pristine countryside completely flat if
you want to okay it's just good business
or visualization right you know you know
that I'm in this particular portion of
the map because it looks you know
untouched by five you know the
unfortunate here's the destruction of
about people using this crater here is a
little bit of cover you see they drop
right down and you can you can take
cover here behind the wall and pop up if
you want to but those those explosions
allow you to change the environment
right from above here also a couple of
things too there are certain structures
you can actually level completely yeah
and it will create a crater underneath
as well so for people who may be
concerned about like you know the look
maybe a building completely flat line
and there's no covers there's
opportunity for that because of the
ground information yeah I mean it's
almost like if you think about it this
way the floorboards sort of crumpled in
on themselves and there's a bit of space
underneath so if you crouch now then
there's that still that tiny bit of wall
that's been left behind and you're still
able to take a bit of cover there so you
might be out in the middle of nowhere
with the people firing down on you but
you've got the opportunity to take some
cover and maybe give yourself a little
bit more of a fighting chance he just
jumped out of that area bales know best
he was not having any of that but here
we go now is a team Stone Mountain
trying to push forward but here comes a
tank here and they're gonna get any huge
hit on that tank and the tank goes down
big plays there for stone mountain and
his crew completely decimating that war
machine good work there from them well I
mean like you saw the power at the end
it's Hank grenade there I mean he looks
like a small object in your hand but it
sure got a big explosion when it goes
off and multiple ones of those are
easily going to be able to take down one
of those land ships oh yeah they're just
they're just deadly but you know I think
a lot of people always ask the questions
well you know how do I defend myself
against tanks oh there you saw it right
there working with your team which is
what battlefields all about and you will
be able to over overcome those odds even
if you're just you know just just a
small infantryman yeah I mean it was a
great shot there that we just we just
went past that showed like the mud lands
in between this amazing sort of
countryside and we've got what's already
been destroyed so I was a really nice
shot
you